and we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
psychic your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel
again
being joined by Mikey over here from the
solo one podcast hi hi Jay how are you
I am very well male cocker spaniel um I
don't know why I said that but you know
I'm trying to take it personally that's
fine all good all good let's just I'm
Gonna Roll the credits and then we'll
crack on foreign
because I've had a little bit of a
problem with this earlier but okay I
think we are but uh I can check my phone
if you want yeah well I'll just check
mine as well while I'm just making sure
make sure I'm not talking to ourselves
um no we are and I've and I can see
myself okay oh good that's fantastic oh
there we go
but anyway so right Star Trek yeah card
season three airs on um well tomorrow in
the United States because they're
selfish and here in the UK because we're
second-class citizens on Friday
um
I bet Amazon must be gutted I did hear
at one point Amazon were getting it the
day after but now I don't think they are
I don't know
on Amazon Prime at one point but
the first two seasons were advertised as
Amazon Prime production now they've got
Prime now they've got primary it's all
up in the air isn't it you never know
quite where you stand at the moment so
it's um you know I just glad it's
finally here it's been a very very long
wait
um and um you know we've been talking
about it on my show for for months um
and looking at a lot of the um early
people have had some early screeners
um and some of those harsh critics
have also seen them and from what I've
heard it's a lot of positive feedback so
what have you heard your end what do you
think about myself I unfortunately know
quite a lot of people that got to go
to the president yeah okay through the
channel and through talking to people
like Sean Ferrick he got to go so I saw
it I know it's very smugged at me when
he came out yes he did
um and the podcast boys and a few others
um and I hate all of them I hope we'll
have some sort of Star Trek related
accident
um
transport accident is it or is it a an
Enterprise truck on their heads I don't
know
um Borg attack whatever really I'm from
civilization yeah yeah I'm just very
jealous and angry
um
but now these lucky sides got to go to
to see it and um yeah very cool um it
must have been very cool because
obviously the actors and everything were
there Denise Crosby wasn't there
they forgot to invite her taxi yeah
I've actually met I've actually met to
these Crosby and she was really nice so
I went to a convention in Birmingham a
couple of years ago and it's the first
one I ever went to and um I was there
with my daughter and we looked at her
she saw us and we were talking she'll go
and talk to her and she's all beckoned
us over she was really really nice yeah
so it's very strange when you actually
meet people that you see on the shows uh
but yeah I thought why she's not been
invited so now it is strange
um I've never really met anyone famous
but I've spoken to people famous on
Twitter and stuff and I'll tell you what
it's not always the best experience but
um well you know the only person I've
really met that was actually I'm wearing
this t-shirt that's that's a suspicious
Liam thing
um I met Dave Grohl
um
um it was when caller and the shape just
came out and they weren't massive
ovaries so they were just playing quite
small venues so we literally went out
the thing went into the pub next door
and then the band walked in and I just
stood in his face going Dave oh my God
um and literally that was so he just
went yes
[Music]
I just carried on point and shouting
Dave in his face but um but he bought
everyone he bought everyone a drink it
was great there's like oh that's good so
he was okay yeah yeah it's
um so yeah no problem anyway back to
Star Trek so yeah can't use it first
thing I wanted to say I did a video a
couple of days ago
um about the Enterprise F so we senior
that
um the Enterprise f is not we we already
knew it wasn't going to be in this
series much it basically does a flyby
um and that that's about it it's a big
celebration fireworks and they
established one but now we're here
actually
um it's having a flyby in a celebration
because it's about to get the mission no
I've heard that I've heard that very
surprised about that
um it's a ship that I've been wanting to
see for many years and it's very clever
twist actually that if a ship that we
finally see the death even though it's
not going to be quote the hero ship of
the actual language series it's actually
been decommissioned
um I've had a bet with my my colleague
Martin on the podcast I'm convinced that
we're going to see the caption of the
Enterprise f
uck I keep saying to him I know who it's
going to be it's going to be Captain
Harry Kim
I just think it's going to I think it's
going to be him because he's going to be
an irony after all those years
it's a running joke isn't he that he's
the least promoted person on the planet
is Ensign Cara hurricane for a long long
very time so yeah and we did see him as
a captain obviously in the future
episodes
um that horrible little ship that he was
aboard but um Rhode Island Rhode Island
the Rhode Island yep
um but what do you think about I mean I
love the Odyssey class I I thought it's
a great design I love the bubble neck
thing I love the thing there are angles
it's not the nicest I I'll be honest
there are a lot of people hate it and in
certain angles
certain angles it's not the prettiest
ship in the world but overall I've
always really really liked it
um what what do you think of the design
I I like it um I mean I'm not a big
gamer but I'm very familiar with the
class from over the years it's been
around for a long time the only bit I
don't know which sounds a bit weird is I
don't like the the the warpness cells at
the back slightly curve and for some
reason some angles it just doesn't look
quite right if it had been slightly
straighter but it's just you know like I
said we all have sort of pros and cons
with Federation staff ships but on the
whole it looks like a ship that you
wouldn't want to mess with it's it looks
very sturdy it's very structurally sound
and of course Enterprises tend to get
bigger as they as the ones go along
um so yeah I've always thought it was a
really cool design
um I I would hope that would sit to a
relative degree in Picard season three
but whether it's going to be just a very
short flyby I don't know well I've got a
horrible feeling we're going to see it
as much as we see it
yeah it would make sense if Speedy
commissioned for Picard to visit it and
that's why Picard's there so we might we
may get to see it a bit more I don't
know but
um I just think it's a shame that we're
going to get to see this vessel finally
get to see it and we're never going to
see her again
no
um and that is a massive shame but it
does open the opportunity because there
are loads guys G yes with a G
um I don't know what series that would
be in
I don't I'd look for me I'd love the
Next Generation Next Generation aboard
the Enterprise G boom series that's it
simple but I don't think they'll do that
if I'm 100 honest what do you think will
happen if this is a really big success
um and um Terry metallis gets the chance
of making a brand new series what would
you think the direction they would take
I I think the the surprise success of
strange new worlds has thrown everything
open now if we assume
um they stay with a production company
they're with at the moment because there
has been a lot of rumors that actually
um they might change production
companies because Paramount I've not
been particularly happy with kurtzman
Okay
um
but if they do
so because one of the things I keep
talking about is that we don't actually
know what's coming after the couple of
series we know so we know Discovery five
we've got another four to six we know
we've got the two animated series coming
but we know nothing about after that
we don't even know anything about if
there's a third series of strange new
worlds that's right but we know Picard's
ending
so one of the rumors is that all these
things are not being announced because
actually they're going to reboot it and
they're going to switch right production
companies I don't think they will I
don't think so either but I do think
um the success of strange new worlds has
sort of made them stop and have and have
a reassess
yeah I I agree I think from my
perspective strategy worlds was a real
breath of fresh air because it it was
back to familiar territory of Standalone
episodes in an era that all right it was
a pretty cool and you've said before
you're not a big fan of prequels in some
ways I'm not either
um but the way that it came across it it
felt more like Star Trek should be
um we a lot of people have got uh
problems with Discovery I do too it's
definitely the least familiar Star Trek
series I've ever seen
um and I I just think that I would hope
that they are the thing is they are
listening to the fans part of the reason
why strange new worlds came about was
because people said well look Discovery
is just not what we want and they they
did they did do that in their defense
and I also think that I personally think
with with the Picard series
um the reason why it's taking three
seasons to get to this point is because
Patrick Stewart wanted a series about
John Luke Picard he didn't want a
startup Next Generation uh season eight
kind of thing he wanted it to be
focusing on his own character and slowly
as the time's gone by they've managed to
persuade him with season three to think
well look this is the real end of the
Next Generation this is going to be like
the undiscovery was for the original
series let's bring back the whole gang
and have a farewell adventure thing a
bit like like the he said I made another
film after Nemesis which is what they
were planning this way they've got even
longer season you've got 10 episodes
probably about 45 minutes each to
properly wrap things up and say goodbye
to this era of Star Trek so we've got 10
hours of Star Trek yeah
well but yeah so I yeah I'm not sure I'm
not sure what's going to go next
um I don't think we're going to get the
section 31 that was removed for a long
time I don't think that's happening
Michelle and if they do if they do do it
it won't be Michelle yeah the other one
was
um Star Trek Academy
for years that's been muted for about 30
40 years so well the comic books are so
popular but Gene Roddenberry actually
wrote A series based on Stafford Academy
so that's been gone back to like to look
at that a few times but it it they can't
we don't want Star Trek 90210 I just I
just don't want it
um and I think it's good yeah
but I I think they have gone back and
recess I would love is the seven of nine
Series Baseball the Titan that would be
cool
for what I understand I think a lot of
that there I mean one thing about going
back to Discovery was that they had the
bridge crew still really don't really
remember remember them after four I mean
I know it's Detmer and what's a [__] is
the two female characters on it but I
only learned that after four years
apparently the characters on the new
Titan aren't going to really stand out I
know that one that's going to be uh
jordy's daughter and there's going to be
a bald Vulcan I think as well and I
think there might be a uh uh I don't
know I know some other races as well
um and what I understand is that it's
been written in a way that in some ways
it could be potentially and again this
is all hypothetical an introduction into
them being on their own series the next
next Generation kind of thing I don't
know whether that's true or not but I
hope that at least it's a possibility
this is my face is in that astronaut's
head
I did that for our show I did that oh
you never said about it so maybe where's
um
I'll leave it there for for next time on
on over with you guys I'll turn it off
next time I promise
I just know what the [__] is that who's
that gorgeous film
all right um but yeah I mean it just
seemed to me there's been a lot of
development work and if they're not
thinking about
Stargate Titan Star Trek Titans I've
just filmed literally three Stargate
videos but it happens it happens
um but um but yeah unless they're doing
a Star Trek Titan with seven of nine I
know
um Jerry Ryan is got a small part in
another series she's going off breaking
up a bit at the moment
okay
yeah your your Signal's not great I
don't understand my internet signal is
great this evening and the kids are here
so they're um sucking up all my uh me
too okay what about now I think I think
we're okay now because what you're
saying sorry excellent so and I know
she's off for a little series but
apparently it's not a big part so she
could come back
um
if they the section 31 thing is still a
possibility but it won't be with
Michelle yo
um but I I just don't want them to do a
very focused series that like that would
be
um and it's it's
we we want we want the starship
you know I I think that's what most
wanted I mean
section 31 we're so very cleverly
introduced in season six of DS9 and uh
he had Sloan and everything else and
they were in the background and then
they appeared also in Enterprise which
was quite interesting but again though
in the background well the case
Discovery they were they weren't the way
they're originally written they actually
had like black com badges they were
actually more of a sort of had its own
identity where the whole point of
section 31 was that they were really in
the background they really
kind of like in themselves in the
Federation doing their own bet in the
background rather than and and I don't
know whether a Star Trek series would be
strong enough with section 31 I don't I
I don't know where it would go which
might be that interesting to follow yeah
it's not even that it's not even like
Starfleet intelligence is it it's a
section of Staff link intelligence it's
supposed to be ultra I don't I don't
want to see it I'm not interested
um and also I don't want another time
frame we've got four time frames at the
moment we don't need any more we've got
obviously we've got the Picard time
frame which is 20 years ago where the
animated is we've got discovery which is
another 100 and something years ahead of
that and we've got strange new worlds
which is seven years before the original
series that's enough different time
frames thank you very much I agree I
agree yeah I do not need to have to make
notes every time I watch a Star Trek
series to figure out nearly did it again
a Star Trek series to figure out which
bloody time frame I'm looking at
um and
um it confuses the things and they end
up Trump stepping on their own toes and
I don't but hopefully we won't can I ask
a question um
to Star Trek was that the um there were
three series which was set all around
the same time
um in the 24th century
um and they actually continued they did
overlap but it I what I liked about that
era was that you'd have crossovers
events for one series could actually
affect another and that to me was one of
the strengths of that period and maybe
partly why Enterprise failed
um was again it was it went to a prequel
era whereas perhaps if they'd made the
series after Voyager again in a similar
time frame do you think that might have
helped it out if they've done that or I
think it would have worked okay to the
new series is that what you're saying
yeah I mean um I think the there's a few
reasons why Enterprise
maybe didn't succeed
I think one of the reasons was the
biggest reason possibly was for me they
promised to show us how the Federation
formed and then they just didn't
and they started messing around with the
temporal war and all that sort of thing
instead so they sort of didn't give us
what they were supposed to if that makes
sense right um so but I actually really
I actually really liked it I actually
genuinely still think one of the best
Star Trek full stop Star Trek episodes
ever was an Enterprise episode called
regenerations
um which was sort of like a follow-on
for us that's a big one wasn't it that
was a book follow on from first Contact
yeah great I wish we should have been a
double episode fantastic episode
um I really like Scott and bacula as the
captain
it's all I liked trip I like I liked it
I liked all the characters
um that's the reason why I don't like
Discovery the characters are born as
crap
um that's why I could not I could not
name a single character from Discovery
except Michael and I only remember that
because her name's a boy's name I don't
get it that's my name so they go there
you go
um so yeah um but I I don't I don't get
it
um that's I also think why strange new
worlds is so fantastic because they've
got the characters right the characters
are great but the characters are
brilliant in Enterprise some of the
stories wandered around the temple Cold
War crap weird weirded me out and
um what about zindy um The Promise
that's the problem they didn't fulfill
the promise I mean Enterprise had a very
good third season I thought with the
zindy whole War I think it was quite
entertaining I don't know whether it
should have been a whole season-long
thing but I think for the most part it
actually worked very well and the fourth
season was clever because it had lots of
three or four episode arcs in in the
fourth season which and of course had a
fantastic Mirror Universe episode which
was not only a prequel but it was also a
sequel from the original series which
was so clever yeah
um
things
such a good episode there were rumors
that they were supposed to be
um a lot of mirror of the universe in
the fifth season
um that was going to be the overarching
story
I think Enterprise would have survived
if they'd have done the refit at the
start of series four so it comes back
from this Indie conference
so if they'd have put that in and had a
souped-up Enterprise the refit
Enterprise I think that would have that
would have stood up a bit more interest
um trackies would have loved it and I
think it could have survived into season
five but they didn't the plan was that
was supposed to be the start season five
they were going to do the refit and I
think they held off too long but
um
I mean that's the problem why the actual
season was rushed at the End season four
with the Next Generation crew
um which a lot of people hated the last
episode of that uh I actually didn't
mind it but I could see why a lot of
people hated it so I think it's a good
season Ender if you're ending this
evening with that episode Not a Bad
episode but it was the series finale it
was the end of the whole thing as a
series finale it was terrible
um if that had just been the end of
season for going on to season five um I
think people would have quite liked it
but as a series finale
but then we'll get back to Pecan a
little bit because there's a couple
things I wanted to of course sorry yes
so
I I do have a couple of concerns about
card season three but a lot of these
concerns were based more from like four
or five months ago because you know
season one let's you know I've said this
a million times but season one Let's
Dance season two let us down you know we
only want sort of thing yes and but fool
me three times and I'm and I'm the idiot
sort of thing so but everything it looks
like it looks like this is going to be a
brilliant series of Star Trek it looks
like it might actually be the Star Trek
series season that these characters
deserve so
jobs are good everyone
but
the two characters I was a bit concerned
by Moriarty and law
I mean they're horn shoeing
um Brent Spiner into the series again
all right but the law is supposed to be
taken apart on a star base somewhere and
Moriarty was supposed to be on a memory
chip aboard the Enterprise d
very quickly
um in the Next Generation there was an
episode where
um the Holodeck the computer went wrong
and they said it create a program
intelligent enough to to defeat data and
it created Moriarty and it made him very
smart and everything
I'm convinced that there's going to be
something where Moriarty is brought back
as a program to defeat law
I just think there might be some sort of
link with the fact that
I don't know it's just an idea I had
what do you think about that is that
possible what do you think is possible I
don't see why it's not a possible idea
why not
um obviously law is in it at some point
when I don't understand why Geordie knew
it was law and didn't think it was B4
because when Geordie sees him through
the window
be he Geordie would think and unless
there's something that we don't know yet
unless they know that law is knocking
around and he might then the Jordan
might already know he's escaped or
something we don't know about that point
but when he sees him through the window
he goes law but he knows before is
around he doesn't know that law is
around as far as we know so I didn't get
that
um I don't get why law is all old but I
think that's going to be skin
um
um the Moriarty thing when you see
Moriarty it does look like he's in a
hollow chamber so it's being projected
oh yeah okay
okay I'm wondering whether the the
villain that we don't know the captain
of this strike we don't know who she is
where she's come from but she knows
Jean-Luc and Jean-Luc knows her yeah and
as soon as he sees it he goes we've got
to get out of here all right so
he knows her so we're gonna know her
she's she's got to be a character from
The Next Generation is my theory okay in
which case she's brought
Moriarty and and law back and it's I I
don't know if she's messing with John
Luke somehow
yeah
haunting him sort of thing you know like
bringing back ghosts from the past
apparently Moriarty isn't in it much
he's only pretty much in it for a couple
of minutes and he's not in there oh is
he oh
okay I wasn't aware um
he's like the harbinger of the new sort
of thing and he's there to tell
and he's and it's all thing to like like
say ghosts
building up towards what then happens
and that's why Lord's there as well
um in which case I've been racking my
brain trying to think which villain it
could be
and the only thing I can think is it's
got to be Borg related
because that ship
that that strike that's right by the
spiky looking thing it looks a bit boggy
which isn't a word but we're going with
it okay and but also it kicks the
Titan's ass
and another ship it kicks another ship
well so it's it's a formidable vessel so
where she got it from
her skin looks like it's partly damaged
I mean it's I mean I don't know whether
there's some evidence that she might
have been have some uh assimilated with
the Borg or something like that
um it's it's the ball cabin used in
during the entire series the first
season had a cube the second season we
had the Queens so they might want to
continue and the book are the the
biggest villain to have appeared in the
Next Generation era
um but I suppose really I mean with
regard to jordy's saying law it that
that could have just been the editing of
the actual trailer I mean the the one
thing you have to keep in mind is that
often Traders they are just bits and
pieces they just throw them together for
dramatic effects yeah
um but as you say now if law is aging
now apparently data did have a program
to age it was mentioned in an episode of
season seven of the Next Generation I
think it's the one where we discovers
his mother which was actually uh another
law uh sorry another some Android that
we saw
um but why law is we're in the Starfleet
uniform for one thing and he's he's got
the yellow eyes but his skin does look
like it's the normal human figures and
his hair is white
which tells me that there's something as
has happened that we need to know what
it is but in what respect I don't know
we've seen images as well that is not in
the trailer but there's been a couple of
images knocking around with again Brent
Spina in the uniform stood on the deck
uh on a on like on the bridge okay of
some vessel um which again made me think
it's before
but initially when I saw those because
again that would make sense data's
memory was put into B4 at the end of
um
um Nemesis Nemesis Nemesis Nemesis we
start seeing that his memory is seem to
be coming through so I thought it made
sense to use before but it doesn't look
like the floor so well I mean from what
I understand from the first season the
um the data's Consciousness was put into
B4 but B4 was too primitive to run the
software kind of thing it was like um a
Windows XP running a Windows 95 program
or something yeah okay
um I still think that law technically is
a much more uh Better Built Android yeah
so whether there's some way that
um because I assume that the memories of
data would still be in the deactivated
B4
yep so if that's the case can they
simply if they've got law and it's been
reactivated because he was taken apart
as well because data's Essence be then
put into B4 maybe they have some sort of
um Personality Crisis like a
schizophrenia thing where law could be
fighting with aspects of data could that
be a possible yeah why not um and let's
say I'd be interested in to bring sort
of data somehow back into it they might
just say that law because he is more
advanced was programmed to age and he
had the emotion ship and everything they
might just explain it like that because
yeah I was always moving to explain
because they do I mean the way they
explained Q was quite funky they just
thought oh I'll catch up yeah that's it
that's explained that's it they do
explain it they didn't explain why um
um
uh from 10 forward uh why would be gold
oh that was a real that was a real mess
up because we saw geinen in the 19th
century
um and then of course we've seen guynn
again in the 21st century but she was
then played by a different actress so of
course we know the reason why is because
of course Guyana was younger when they
filmed
um Time Zero I think it was called back
in uh and of course the the new ones
only filmed a couple of years ago but
that I I find that a bit annoying I'd
rather just not have seen guyanan played
by a different actress exactly I just
would say I'm bothered yeah that was
redundant yeah and then they also did
that trying to do that whole thing
trying to explain why the eloreans were
watches and all this sort of thing and I
just wish they'd left it out but they
had to put it in because they didn't
have enough story for season two well
that's the problem with it
I've lost you for a second there
we'll see if he comes back
anyway guys get into the comments tell
us what you think about season three
you're looking forward to it or are you
thinking it's just going to be one more
disaster from kurtzman or are you
actually thinking Terry metallic is
running this but Terry metallics did
actually write and work on the other two
seasons he's not coming into this fresh
he has always worked on other projects
as well but he hasn't just come into
this completely fresh so
is Terry metallis the man to take Star
Trek and star forwards or do we think
that actually it might be somebody else
oh yeah Mike is back thank God all right
thank you I did hear what you say about
Terry mattalis
um I think from what I've seen of his I
mean like I said I could really only
answer your question once I've seen
season three but at the moment it's
pointing that he potentially could be
the person that we need
um to continue Star Trek in whatever
form that will be whether that happens
or not but I I'd still got some worries
concerns until The Season's finished so
ask me in 10 weeks time and I'll be able
to tell you probably a bit more uh
confidently I mean Season Two started
brilliantly
so the season two is he wrote episode
one of season two um and I was just like
and then the rest of the season it just
sort of went I want to jump off a
Clearfield
um it did a complete Lemmings um so I
hate it
um there's so many things about it I I
actually not argued with but I had a
debate with Terry Morales on Twitter
about
um Picard season two now they neutered
the Borg and ruins the best villain in
sci-fi and he said no they're not the
same as the Borg this is her girati's
Collective um separate Collective it's
not part of the main Hive is it or
something but the point I made then was
like okay so she has created her own
Hive so she's enslaved tens of thousands
of beans yep I'm not sure girati is the
good guy
and I also pointed out that jarati all
girati actually had to do was lift up
her visor and go it's me
hi but that was made very good that
would have obviously defeated the whole
point of the actual mystery as you say
that's a plot hole but they did that for
the actual dramatic effect where'd you
say just like oh it's me oh okay it's
fine we'll then put the ideals up yeah I
don't mind plot holes I don't mind leaps
of logic I do mind when something's just
stupid
and and that was just stupid the whole
season was a complete waste of time
really if you think about it
um but I do I do live with the relative
that sometimes things happen because the
story has to happen so I was like why
did that happen why have they just
talked about that there when they could
have just not because the story needs to
happen because we're watching so these
things need to you know so you have to
have plot devices and blah blah blah I'm
just a little bit disappointed when it's
just thick and you know that's but
anyway
what do you think about
um the possibility well Patrick
Stewart's already said this might not be
the end of a card and even though he is
903 years old and he's he's doing very
well for his age yes but he he is not an
idiot woman
um but Gates McFadden
um uh Marina certis and Jonathan Frakes
have all talked about maybe
there being a possibility of future
Adventures of the TNG crew
um for me Michael Dawn and bringing wolf
back is the easiest I mean but they've
been talking about doing a wharf scene
he's wanted to do his own suits for many
many years he's pitched into Paramount
and all sorts of things it's never
happened
begged but yeah basically
is that something you'd want to see
I I think that um I I'm reminded a bit
of Stargate season eight where O'Neill
was more kind of like just the commander
he was he was less in the Forefront he's
slowly his role went more in the
background
um what might work is some sort of
transitional thing where we have some of
the Next Generation crew in in a command
perspective or something with a new crew
which I think they may be doing in
Picard season 3 anyway and slowly
transition to a new crew that we know
and the Next Generation characters
slowly become more in the background I
think that's something which might
happen I don't know whether this is
supposed to be the last ever season or
story of the Next Generation Chrome yeah
so uh and like I'm also thinking of
generations where we did see three of
the original series crew for the
transitional thing of the next
generation's first movie
so I I would think that that would be
the way it would go rather than saying
well look we just did season three of
the card it was a huge success you know
what we're all going to come back and do
another season and call it Starship
Picard 2 or something that being too was
I don't know so I mean what do you think
about it
I I do think if this series is popular
and a few of the actors want to come
back I could see them doing appearing in
whatever the next project is right I
suspect they've got a plan with this I
say spectator knows what the next thing
and I actually think as soon as the last
or just before the last episode of
season three of Picard we'll we'll know
what this next series is going to be
because they'll announce it yeah I
suspect
um
I don't know whether it'll be a wharf
series or it'll just be a different or
it'll be a seven of I mean for me I want
the seven of nine on on the Titan that's
what I want
um and there may be a few of the
characters from TNG will
will will be her group or something I
don't know or they'll just appear
like they did in Picard season two like
you know Marine acidity and a Troy just
turned up junk and Frakes turned up but
they weren't big Parts they just sort of
yeah woven into the story a little bit
and we just got a flash of them maybe
maybe we do that but Gates McFadden has
been on Twitter and she has said look
guys if you want us to come back in some
sort of project it's up to you so she
was sort of hinting you know if you call
for it they might do it so it would
suggest it's been at least discussed
I've heard now I don't know if you
watched the Mandalorian but the end of
season two of The Mandalorian the
episode ended and it had a post-credits
scene where Boba Fett is back with a
brand new series it was a surprise
nobody knew about it and it was a huge
thing I've heard that there's going to
be a post credit scene at the end of
episode 10 which will have some big
surprise
I think so I it that would complete 100
make sense to me and look it seems to me
that they are they've took a leaf out of
Marvel's book I think they tried to do
it a little bit in season two but it
failed but they are really making sure
we I look at the end of the day the
captain of this strike vessel I do know
a name but I've forgotten it I'll keep
it figuring it as well
um we don't know who the hell she is no
and that's very much on purpose there's
another character that fella and we no
idea who he is
um you know it's just like there's just
I think they've been very careful to
make sure that his name if you've got an
IMDb it's just oh no okay and they've
not released it so they're being very
careful to make sure we don't know a
great deal if you actually think about
the trailers
very vague yeah very vague we know
there's a villain we know there's a
battle which I'm really looking forward
to another good space battle me too I
love space packing I'm a [__] for a
good space battle so am I yeah um so we
know that but actually what else can you
take from that trailer there's very
little we know dwarf head butts
um
we know dwarf headbutz Rafi and rafi's
got a problem and we and we basically
know there's this threat and that's it
that's it we don't know anything else
I thought very much on purpose I think
I've heard that most of the trailer is
only because
consists of stuff from the first two
episodes as well so I think a lot of the
stuff that um uh we're not going to see
yet so it's it's very minimal they're
very very secretive there's been a lot
of fan service apparently there's gonna
be a lot of ties in with and potentially
some crossovers with other Star Trek
24th century era shows like Voyager and
DS9 but I love crossovers that's what I
loved about Atlantis um sg1 and Atlantis
they had a lot of crossovers at one
point so if there are crossovers I'd
love to see that I have a dream is that
they they thought it was going to be or
part of the things going to be filmed on
DS9 they're part of it that people said
in the background they thought it looked
like the Promenade and things but I
think that might be people getting a bit
I I have heard of one scene I'm not I
don't know if I spoil it but I know that
there's one scene in a very familiar
location
um but I'm not gonna say because it's
quite big but I don't know what that
will entail but um yeah but I don't know
I mean I'm hearing lots of different
things of different things it's in the
trailer just tell us but it's not in the
trailer oh okay well done telling them
um
let's just say let's just say that where
they're filming it does have carpets
that's what I'm saying what kind of is
it my house I've got carpets hmm it's a
familiar
um
place that you saw in the Next
Generation it's something that you see a
lot of in the Next Generation
that's the Enterprise D then
okay I I Picard does say there are
multiple Enterprises yeah so that's
gonna be there's gonna be something to
do with that that's all I think that's
all I've heard of that no I mean the D's
destroyed
but it could be um yeah but also it
could be that the actual sources recover
from Viridian three I could have
recovered The Source
um it could be a museum there because
yeah that's um uh thing that's like Star
base from Star Trek 3 Apparently that is
a museum yep e could be a museum F could
be we will hopefully we'll see the F
yeah and we might even see a launch of
the G you never know but oh I'd love to
say that I want somebody I want a bit of
f though personally yeah oh yeah I love
it
and the I'd love to see the G though
because on Canon we don't know what the
G is so they've they've they've created
the f as the Odyssey which I think is
very cool they brought the game design
in very good
um they don't have to do that for the G
but there is a game version of the G
there is there is a g and it's got two
deflected dishes it's really chunky if
it's the way I'm thinking I can't
remember the class of it yeah I haven't
seen it for a while I vaguely remember
it's quite cool but they don't have to
do that they can do whatever they want
because it's Canon so um on screen they
can do something so they could actually
create a Starship that we've not seen
before and you know what we're like
we'll go effing crazy
so yeah I'd love to see that well I've
done it also they've also created their
own I mean they did the Stargazer last
season they've got the Titan a this
season so they can they've got the
creativity to make a good looking brand
new starship if they made the Enterprise
G themselves which would be then Canon
that huge for the Star Trek fan base
yeah um and I I actually adored the
Stargazer I'm in two minds about the
Titan some angles of the Titan I love it
and when it when it was actually there's
the scene in the trailer when he's sort
of like it's scooting across the top of
the base yes
I was thinking oh that looks good that
does but then you'd see another angle
like the back end of the um saucer
section you're just like all the impulse
engines yeah and drawn by a child but
what it looks like in in parts is that
they've got a bit of the Constitution
and I'm going to take a bit of um an
Excelsior class and I'm gonna take a
little bit of this and then I'm gonna
stick it all together and oh look at a
new ship and I'm just like now design a
new ship
um don't do it that it reminds us of
lots of others so do you do you wish
they hadn't made a sort of retro kind of
like it's not it's called a constitution
three or a Neo Constitution do you think
they should have had just more of a
modern kind of 25th Century aesthetic
ships design that we've seen like the
Stargazer or well it does look like a
throwback doesn't it it doesn't look
like
um a vessel that would follow a
sovereign class it looks like a vessel
that would have been built before it
before the Galaxy even that's what it
looks like so it does look like a bit of
a throwback but it looks like a sort of
movie era 23rd Century Eros or like uh
that you know the part for the sales
look a bit more modern but apart from
that but but I I am I am 100 confident
that we'll fall in love with it I didn't
like the Voyager when it first came out
and I adored it by the end oh boy just
gorgeous design yeah it's lovely ship
but I didn't like it before because they
the whole thing with the with the warp
and cells irritates
yeah why do that that's unnecessary
There Was an explanation about that
apparently it was to stop pollution but
I buy a wall travel it was the warp
Vector in it created a warp vector and
to stop the
um space-time deterioration damage yeah
yeah yeah yeah so um
space and things wasn't it but yeah so I
don't know why doing that though because
that if we just angle the warp engines
at 45 degrees if that's the problem
that's it if I saw it that's it Jesus
Christ yeah it was a bit of a it was
just to make it look cool that it goes
it's better than what JJ Abrams did with
the Enterprise so let's just with all
the Flappy bits
I'm so glad that isn't getting a Star
Trek 4. I'm so pleased
they keep saying that it's still
possibly it's still on the cards I'm
hearing doing things all the time it's
it's pretty much dead at the moment
basically I've just been talking about
this because it's related to Stargate
um JJ Abrams has got an and Bad Robot
has got an exclusivity deal with
Paramount with with them sorry with um
Warner Brothers
okay and it's a four-year deal they pay
250 million dollars
um but they've actually over the four
years produced nothing
it's not completely their fault the deal
was signed to late 2019 and then you
know
stuff happened
um Frozen again but anyway so
um so so it's not completely their fault
they haven't produced anything and
Warner Brothers apparently about six
months ago was seriously contemplating
suing Bad Robot
um because of this I'm not doing
anything and they kept pitching ideas
and they're just and Warner Brothers
just kept saying no so
um but
so then so then they announced Star Trek
IV because they were trying to get out
of this exclusivity deal right
um but now it looks like David's aslaf
the new guy and head of Warner Brothers
are sort of they've built a few Bridges
and now a couple of projects have been
thrown
um bad robots away they're going to be
doing Constantine two they're going to
be doing another project so it looks
like the relationship has sort of been
mended a little bit okay five robot
we're going out and trying to find other
deals trying to find other projects
would not have been allowed to do Star
Trek 4. oh really okay the only thing
they could have done JJ Abrams could
have gone on separate from Bad Robot as
a producer
um but even that was slightly dodgy but
that's why when he announced Star Trek 4
none of the crew knew none of the staff
none of the none of the surprised they
were all surprised yeah because it was a
bit of a um Hail Mary apparently and it
backfired
yeah let's just saying I mean I I what
did you think of the Kelvin series of
films in general were you very anti them
were you indifferent to them did you
just see them as popcorn flicks or what
they're fun movies they're popcorn
movies they're good Sci-Fi Action
they're not Star Trek yeah
I think it's fair and and that goes for
me is like just look at the three
different Enterprises they threw out
they're just they're just terrible
um but yeah fun films
I think I agree entirely it's um but
what is it that makes Star Trek Star
Trek I I it's I mean you and I kind of
know what it is but how do you explain
that to a non uh sort of expert
the way I was sort of I tried to explain
something else I think I think science
fiction
basically Star Trek is science fiction
heavy on the science right yeah
everything's supposed to be grounded in
some sort of theory and then they create
a fiction
the JJ Abrams movies with science
fiction heavy on the fiction yeah
that makes sense
using a black hole to to try to go
travel through is just not they go it
causes time dilation right yes it does
so we can fly through it right no no you
can't
if you fly near one time slows down
that's the science don't fly through a
[__] hole no and and and and they
made the Enterprise water powered
oh Brewery wasn't it it was like a
brewery it was really strange yeah
awful but so they just that sort of
thing and like they changed the warp
core three times
but these are the things that trekkies
like we like the details we like the
ships we like the you know we like that
continuity we like continuity
um this is another thing I've had a
problem with with Discovery is that um a
lot of the actual regular races like the
regular races that we know I mean we I
saw Frankie last season I don't think
you've seen the most recent season of
discoveries
something soon make them look like they
did for all those years when
um Michael Westmore did all the makeup
and he was fantastic and surely they can
have someone who could take over what he
did and continue that that continuity is
a big thing for Star Trek it needs to
all slot together and that's one thing
which has had a difficulty in the new uh
era of Star Trek unfortunately well this
is why pre-course stuff annoying me
because it just it ends up just
trampling on Canon but hey look we we
let them we let a lot slide with Star
Trek oh yeah a bit open-minded yeah yeah
they've always [__] Canada
from day one
um but I I do think there's so much Star
Trek it's hard not to you know like you
would have to have some sort of Genius
that can remember every single episode
and every single line to be Consulting
all the time to not mess Canon up
sometimes
um but it's more it's more messed up
these days than it was in the Rick
Berman era I think it's to a large
degree it held together relatively okay
but since it finished in 2005 with all
the new stuff there's been a lot less uh
connection with continuity I think the
way um it was described to me because
those are people a few people in the
industry I speak to and the one one of
the guys is um is um a big creative
director
um and yeah Lily said his name then
um but anyway
um maybe he's a he maybe he's a she I
don't know but what are they yeah um so
um this this first explained to me and
says it's basically Star Trek's a hybrid
um reboot
so you've normally got like
continuations or like a soft reboot Star
Trek next Generation is a soft reboot
it's the the story exists the universe
exists but you've got totally new
characters but everything happened
before still happened continuation or
you've got the hard reboot where it's
basically Battlestar Galactica yes new
story whatever happened before didn't
happen news story new characters here we
go
um Star Trek under kurtzman has been a
hybrid it's been a bit of both so they
were basically told very early on
um
you can pick and choose so certain
things are Canon and certain things just
on
and they've been allowed to get away
with it
um and he was actually talking to me
about this about Stargate because he
says that was his fear with Stargate
that they could decide to go that route
and do this sort of like hybridized um
Canon thing because the main reason is
it's easier for the writers
if the writers aren't fenced in from the
continuity of the accountant yeah yeah
they're allowed to sort of they're
allowed to color Outside the Lines a
little bit at least
um they are allowed to
um it means they can go in different
directions for the story
because otherwise they couldn't so but
we'll see what they end up doing with
thing I don't think if if Mark Fergus
ends up against Target I don't think
he'd do that but um if Bad Robot had got
the Stargate movie which they were
pushing for 100 they'd have done that
yeah they did they'd have made the
argument we need to be creative we can't
be fenced in by Canon
you know that's well one thing I always
I sort of think about is what you've
already said is that basically you know
um Star Trek uh a lot of people that
watch it aren't fans and I think that
that's partly why when it came back with
the Kelvin Universe they had this brand
and they knew that the fans were there
but in the ends
um the percentage of fans compared to
like the Cinematic audience would be
relatively minor now on this new era
with uh Picard season three and strange
new worlds I think they're kind of
realizing that
um it's just as important to have the
fans as happy because they would also
spread positive word of mouth to
potentially less fan-based audience and
make it bigger so I think they might
have learned a bit compared to when the
2016 2008 2009 when the first Star Trek
movie came out
um to where we are now where they are
creative strategy was they are trying to
make a Next Generation complete uh last
season so it's interesting as for
Stargate I mean I don't know I mean
Stargate that is a very
um fan-based series we we love
everything about it we wanted more to to
work but again you know it's if someone
comes and think well look you know I
should say a hybrid is an idea where
they can use aspects of this SG one
series
um but go in its own way I really hope
that they don't do that but in the end
you don't know what's going to happen
the one thing with with Stargate was
they always did stick to Canon
I couldn't think of any Canon I say I I
actually put the challenge out there to
my subscribers and said look what what
were the Canon problems and somebody
said they didn't open us that gun once
and they fired it so at five we left it
pop and open and I'm like guys if that's
the best we can do right I'd say one
they they stopped well they did it's not
it's not cost of Duty because it it does
but they used to have the Zac gun well
as one for Stan two for kill and three
for vaporize and the vaporize stopped
after what the first or second season
but that's not a continuity thing yeah
it could dissipate so if I shot you but
then didn't shoot you again for like an
hour it didn't it'll be back to stand
again the energy dissipates
um but yeah it was very solid
um Stargate it really was it really did
all hold together and I think that's
what made it so special I think having
somebody like Brad Wright that went
through the whole thing helped to keep
it all
um but also the the series I suppose
were very separate you know Atlantis was
very separate she's won and obviously
Universe was completely separate again
so it allowed them to
they didn't step in each other's toes
with it where Star Trek does all the
time well we I say we don't need a
Starship Enterprise I want this is one
of the things I said a strange new
worlds we don't we don't need strange
new laws exchange new worlds was
the same actors but instead of Captain
Pike it was Captain poke
and he was the first or something of the
Endeavor the Farragut the something yeah
yeah exactly they wouldn't have any
issues with like stepping on Canon they
wouldn't have any of us go in right
where's Kirk we always think what this
doesn't make sense and they could have
just done a fun show and we'd have been
just as happy but they're out
with the original series
that's a really good idea they could
have easily have done that where it was
actually just set like 10 years before
the original series on a sister ship
like The Interpreter or something had
its own crew uh and they can still call
it strange
worlds and it could have really had the
same uh look of it but it's a different
ship which is why it was that helped to
stop the continuity issues with the
original Jeffrey Hunter Enterprise with
the handsome Mountain but yeah that
makes sense yeah I could see that but
they had to have the Enterprise in
Discovery didn't they spark and
everything yeah again like I say they're
obsessed through the Enterprise they're
obsessed with Kirk and Spark on all
these characters and I'm like Star
Trek's bigger than that we don't need to
keep revisiting these same bloody
characters over and over again
Enterprise the original Enterprise they
got around saying oh well this isn't the
real Enterprise because it's the NX
Enterprise because we're all going wait
no there wasn't another Enterprise that
is the first Enterprise and then the
Enterprise a b c we know this already so
what yeah and they said NX why didn't
they just call that the Farragut
or Endeavor or something else but
they're obsessed with it they have to
call it the Enterprise and they think
that we won't watch it if they don't
make it Endeavor Star Trek Colombia
because the nx02 was that was shown in
Enterprise they could have made that the
nx01 Starship could be called Star Trek
Columbia
or I mean I love like the Challenger or
something like that Star Trek yeah
but they just but they're obsessed with
the Enterprise and I'm just like I just
they just need to they just need to get
get past it
um we don't care you know what I mean we
I don't get me wrong we love to see the
enterprise we do I want to see the G I
do
um well we don't I don't need a new
series based on it no yeah I see where
you're coming from I can see where
you're coming from I mean it could it
could appear but it doesn't necessarily
have to be the main focus of a brand new
Star Trek series I think yeah well yeah
right we said we'd keep to an hour we're
a couple of minutes off we can we're all
bloody night on Star Trek I know I'm
sorry I go into I love it but it's it's
really good to talk to someone who's got
the like-minded uh information and
knowledge about this incredible
franchise
yeah okay well okay geek I'm certainly a
geek if you're a geek yeah geek I'm a
massive nerd and my wife knows it as
well
who's got a girlfriend
um well listen thank you very much
before you disappeared we've got we've
got two more minutes just very generally
good to finish off
do you think that Star Trek Picard
season three
is going to be a success
very much so do I I I I trust the people
that have seen Harry I'm most confident
about this I've seen since uh Starships
definitely returned on TV in 2017 I am
really confident about this and I know I
should have a bit of trepidation I've
just got too much Good Word of Mouth
from what I'm hearing yeah if it's crap
I hand on my what are you gonna do to
yourself oh no no Joseph I will never
watch
um any of these live action TV series
again
I'm going to continue watching the
cartoon so because the cartoons are
great
Prodigy is the best Star Trek we've had
I've not watched it much yet I've seen
the first few episodes I I I do find it
a bit of a stumbling block with animated
stuff it's like the Star Wars like the
Clone Wars I have watched them I like
them I'm more of a a
um live action show but I have heard a
lot of positive lives from yeah
honestly and the last two episodes were
just brilliant
and it's a proper big space but I know
there's lots of Starships in those yes I
saw that yes
we see them why not destroyed but we see
the end Quest oh spoilers spoilers you
should have been keeping up you should
know this you should have watched my
video I know
I told you that
I'll watch it as soon as this is done
how's that sound thank you if you could
all just watch it about 10 times each
watch the adverts and like and like and
do this yeah
so that's okay no thank you so much Mike
um Everybody yeah Star Trek Picard
season three airs Thursday or Friday
depending on where you are in the world
um get on the channel I will do a video
as soon as I get to watch the first
episode just quickly but guys get onto
the Facebook group getting over us as
soon as you see it drop us your um
opinions without too many spoilers at
first give everyone a chance to watch it
but throw your opinions on my Twitter
feed and whatever as soon as you get to
watch it I'd love to know what you think
of this new series
um thanks everybody in the comments
you've been amazing again
um as Shelley is Shelley is the love of
my life and she's a Canadian lady and
she does my Facebook group and I went
from having like 300 people in my
Facebook group to um 1600 people on my
Facebook because she does all the work
and she doesn't follow Star Trek she's
had no freaking clue what we've been
talking about for an hour and she's
still something wrong
oh hold on Shelly well done thank you
Shelly
um guys thank you so so much um with
spot on the hour like we said we would
be
um I will just throw up the ending
credit sequence and I'll just say
goodbye thanks Mike thanks a lot we'll
see in a few weeks have a good one and
you
[Music]